et moi je suis très honorée que ces
femmes qui pratiquent la boutithérapie
soient venu à mon meeting et je les a
remercie pourquoi et bien parce que ces
femmes ont créé effectivement une
pratique une activité collective qui
vise à quoi qui vise à permettre aux
femmes de se réparer après des traumas
et la la réparation c'est l'un des
objectifs de l'écologie politique
comment est-ce qu'on répare tout ce qui
a pu être détruit tout ce qui a pu être
blessé tout ce qui a pu être abîmé et
donc ce message là il était un il était
important qu'il figure à ce meeting ce
meeting a duré 3 He il était très dense
on y a parlé beaucoup de protection du
vivant qui est lui aussi abîmé qui est
lui aussi blessé qui est lui aussi
détruit qu'il nous faut réparer et on a
parlé de justice sociale avec là aussi
des inégalités Marie tout ça en fait
c'est pas de dire c'est justifi enfin
pas question de remettre en cause la
Bouti thérapie c'est avec des messages
qui sont évidemment éminemment important
le problème c'est de savoir si en
mettant en exerg cela et finalement en
ne donnant pas une explication très très
lisible tout de suite on finit pas par
créer un objet de communication qui rate
sa cible bah écoutez de toute façon
puisquon parle on a beaucoup parlé de ça
et finalement on a moins parlé des des
autres oui mais vous voulez de le faire
et je vous en remercie vous avez bien
expliqué la Bouti thérapie donc c'est la
preuve que c'est possible voilà c'est la
preuve que c'est possible et je sais que
quand il y a des femmes en mini ça fait
jazer les attaques elles viennent quand
même beaucoup de la fchosphère he qui ne
supportent pas quand on voit des femmes
qui ne sont pas dans les mensurations
des magazines qui ne sont pas toutes
blanches qui sont assez peu habillées et
bien la fachosphère s'en donne à cœur
jooie moi je pense qu'il faut dépolluer
les regards voilà et que le problème ce
n'est pas laabouti thérapie et celle qui
la pratique mais que ce sont au
contraire ceux qui le
moque